hello everybody and welcome back to
let's play dead space - okay after my
last recent string of failures I sat
down and reminded myself that I'm a
halfway decent gamer and will not fail
anymore come our jests until here from
here till the end yeah I promise and
that's a promise I'm going to break
probably probably well how are those
barrels there in the first place if they
were just gonna roll down [ __ ] oh
there's lots of them balls oh hello
finish you off yeah that was the wrong
way but whatever
try to get me yeah but I thought Oh give
me that anymore oh I'm an artist with
this thing that all of them yeah
no more ah what's up how'd you know
no ma'am come on
Oh what you lookin at Oh what the hell
Oh little babies come at me bro
BAM
I didn't think that one was gonna hit
any ha ha I'm the best you're the worst
I win you lose well now what now Biddy
yeah okay I think that does it
good job me thank you me make sure I got
all the goodies yeah let's yeah okay
we're good we're here yeah all righty
what what uh-huh
what's the last step per it's what
you're afraid of that it hurts too much
it was her shut up
Stross cross the 4,000 hot - hot diggity
dear here we go turbid dear buhdeuce are
ya alright what did that do haha the
other goodies stuff get there and what
do we look at that
No
what do these barrels is rolling around
ah
Arnold
wah-wah-wah close-quarter actually need
my plasma pistol counter plasma cutter
cutter
Iberia oh there you are come on oh hello
what another one
yep thank you for opening up another
power node hot diggity giving me power
notes well I guess they've always been
giving me guard up
they're giving me more powers
so step
hook that didn't kill you now what do
you what what's going on I'll try to
catch it this time ready and then beat
someone yeah now is it the last one okay
I think was aa goopy goo ah who's that
at least I got out quicker okay let's
see woohoo I got a lot of I need to
carry them all with I'll keep those um
hey I think we're I think we're actually
in pretty good shape I be these more
detonator rounds but that's about it
all right and that'll do
all right I'm doing I'm actually in
really good shape I shouldn't say that
because now I just jinked myself and I'm
gonna die horribly in the next area this
might be a boss store store and save
combo right now each other oh this looks
boss ask what oh what that what you do
in their hotel hotel for your medicine
oops I hold holds more skill there we go
ah happy yo gotcha [ __ ] up
Oh what the hell is going on really
Rick really
ah - ah - okay
now other than that that was just messed
up that black when I kept shooting it
and no limbs would come oh I got a rock
watch out bros I got a rock
I'm going
on the stupid guidance this one's locked
or malfunctioning what I heard that I
heard that ah ha ha Scott yeah [ __ ] oh
you're still alive the hell
nah got ya ha ha ok 2005 season here we
don't need him down there so I don't
know
am I going that
oh I see it's one of the battery
doohickeys
anymore it's awfully big open area for
hmm
where'd you come from
take that in the face yeah Oh your face
go I'll get post yup there you go saw
the thing down here oh no you don't see
ah Oh what someone else wants us yeah
ah damn it
ah what happened there if you didn't see
is I meant to pull the explodey thing
and shoot it at him but as I pulled it
he was puking and it set it off and that
made me break my promise of No More
Deaths okay whatever whatever oh wait
you me weren't there before what the
hell baby
why does stop not do any damage okay
you're gonna stay there are views
and impaled really you're dead now
you're going to be dead Oh
anyway don't go that way first go down
here first forget it I'm just going
and you're there what the hell
that just blowed up slow it all what the
hell baby time for you I have time for
your bull oh who else wants some
aah aah whoa you're fast
what another baby aah
come here give me your good goodies okay
now Oh Houston stasis things Oh baby
yeah it's like a double whammy oh that's
right upgrade the damage on this thing
okay now I see the dead battery over
there see a new battery whoa I see you I
see you Oh way to go where'd you go
ah oh come here where you going running
away scared little baby oh give me your
give me back yeah 300 okay I do not see
another battery or it's right here yeah
do that there I need help I got help oh
that is maja you come from
goodbye me I'm out of ammo for that gun
I on fire
fine gah come on fire away from me okay
anyway and he does I need to upgrade
this who where'd you come from
why not burn you burn too
burn oh no oh there we go okay ah damage
over time
my favorite kind of damage actually no I
like it didn't come front in your face
damage okay all that open that door
we're good I can't say like it cooks it
hello buddy
you're gonna burn how are you and y'all
go hold on a second while I if you do
while I reload here hold on well
actually burn both dead guy deceptive
when they burned it down because it
looks like the sort of death you would
have they were faking
is that rock there
I'll help your dad oh okay anyway moving
on moving on where I don't know where
this road takes tension should workers
be mindful of the nearest surviving
chamber okay
that's morbid thank you save station
tadka there you ha
oh oh that Ellie's i/o holy [ __ ] yeah
you busted what did I do
yeah beat the [ __ ] out of him
that that actually reminds me of
something didn't the captain on Dead
Space 1 get killed just because got
poked in the eye just like ah and then
dead and she got her eye ripped out I
mean I know you can get your eye ripped
out and you'll be fine but my question
is why did the captain died in the last
one okay anyway um that's actually all
the time I got for this episode thank
you guys so much for watching and as
always I will see you in the next part
bye bye